what's up everyone Michael and John Luke
here at PAX West 2019 and we're talking
Final Fantasy 7 remake as we just got
our hands on the game now John Luke you
never played Final Fantasy 7 back in the
day so how does it feel to finally play
this game oh yeah put myself out there
huh yeah yeah it's good I mean I don't
know it's like this demo so short I
don't have like any of the context for
really like picking up the story and the
character it's like okay I know who
cloud is I know Barret eco-terrorism
midgard like I know all that stuff but
like really this demo was like about the
combat which is completely different
than the original Final Fantasy 7 it's
like them continuing off of like trying
to convert their games to more like real
time like action combat I think it's
interesting out square is like still
still feels like they're trying to kind
of figure out like what is good with
that like you know the Final Fantasy 13
was like still had like the turn-based
but they try to make it more like feel
more real time sure I mean like 15 was
like alright we're gonna make it more
like Kingdom Hearts but this game has
like the the ATV system or like it
actually slows it down and they're
trying to capture that feeling of like
tactics we're like okay I'm gonna like
pick what I'm gonna do I think it's an
interesting approach I'm kind of curious
to see how that's gonna like work when
you have like a whole like party yeah
and you're like balancing all these
different abilities it still feels a
little messy with like like the boss is
like doing this like a missile barrage
and I was like I don't know how to like
block or like defend this we're like
without like taking damage or yeah like
it doesn't have that snappiness that
like a like a double make cry does and I
get that that's like maybe an
unrealistic whoa dude commentary yeah
I'm actually a big fan of the system you
know it was one thing to see it during
the e3 presentation now this is the same
demo that was at e3 between 19 so it's
the same section nothing new and it's
one thing to see it in action and it's
another thing to actually experience it
yeah it is a lot more tactical than
maybe you had expect because I when I
saw this emotion like oh I really like
the combat system in Final Fantasy 15 if
they convert that for seven in a
sensible way I'm a fan of that but it is
a lot more tactical where with the ATB
system you stop you got to make your
call about what you're gonna do
it does get a little choppy it's not as
you know I'm not playing like a platinum
action yeah that's exactly yeah
but you know that I like how they're
incorporating the turn-based stuff yeah
I like that better than Final Fantasy 15
I felt like that game could get like a
little messy and chaotic yes because you
couldn't slow it down yeah and it also
kind of lacked the snappiness again eBay
Brian that may yeah made the
decision-making process within battles a
little bit harder but I think that
they've kind of solved that for exactly
I think they Jimmy kind of salt was that
happy now for me who has played five a
seven back in the day and I have all
those memories to come with me
it's something special to see this game
recreated and with all new graphics
obviously and voice acting and you know
seeing these these places that were
low-poly on a ps1 it's fully realized
you know I still want to see how that's
gonna be like how dense this is
obviously we won't know until we get the
game but I am excited for that yeah like
even that short section we played I
could just tell there was a lot of
production value put up to it so like
even though I maybe don't necessarily
have the context for like how it felt
before I can tell just like this is
gonna be like a very well polished like
high budget game that I think a lot of
people are just gonna be like really
impressed with so that was our time with
Final Fantasy 7 remake and you can
overthrow corrupt corporations on March
3rd 2020 when the first part of Final
Fantasy 7 remake comes out for
PlayStation 4
[Music]